what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and with black panther
wakanda forever finally being in
theaters that marks the last movie of
Marvel's phase four we do have the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
but that isn't a full movie so now we
are entering phase five of the MCU but
most importantly we are truly entering
the Multiverse Saga of the MCU yes
technically phase four is part of the
Multiverse Saga however it wasn't
exactly what we thought it would be it
was the start but now we are really
going to dive into it especially with
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania coming
in February and the big introduction of
Marvel's new big bad Kang the Conqueror
the master of time this will truly get
us started with the Multiverse Saga and
lead up to Avengers Secret Wars and
today we have some really cool details
about Avenger Secret Wars details that
fans have been wanting and have been
hoping for for a very long time and it's
looking like everybody's hopes and
dreams are actually going to happen in
Avengers Secret Wars So today we're
going to be talking about a pretty big
plot point of Avengers Secret Wars one
that fans have definitely been hoping
for now Avengers Secret Wars in the
comics is about the Multiverse just like
we're going through in the MCU right now
and what ultimately ends up happening is
that all of the universes kind of
collide into each other and they leave
only one Universe left now there is the
story of battle world in the comics but
I don't think we're going to go down
that route in the MCU per se it's more
likely going to be a simple Multiverse
incursion story where the entire
Multiverse itself is threatened every
Universe in the Multiverse will be
threatened with destruction so the
heroes from each Universe are going to
have to band together making a
multiversal Avengers team a multiversal
superhero team to go up against one king
the Conqueror and two whoever else might
be on King's side because if you think
it's just King that we're going to have
to worry about you might be wrong
because Kang most likely has an army and
his army most likely includes variants
of characters that we know and love
because keep in mind in other universes
some of our heroes might actually be
villains and could actually be on Kang's
side and we could possibly see this
start to happen as early on as an
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania rumor
has it that we'll see some variants in
that movie which variants will see of
which characters remains to be seen but
today we do have a little bit of details
about Avengers Secret Wars coming from
our buddy Paul over at heavy spoilers a
friend of the channels we'll move on and
I'll get right into it and right now
everybody's talking about what he said
in his latest video giving some details
of what we might see in Avengers Secret
Wars this is what he has to say in
regards to what Marvel Studios is
President Kevin feige wants for Avengers
Secret Wars and trust me the fans want
this too here's what Paul had to say
feige's dream and his vision is to have
a similar scene to the portals one at
the end of Avengers end game however
instead of just being restricted to MCU
characters we'll have multi multiple
Marvel franchises converging at this
point this will include Toby Maguire and
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man Hugh Jackman
as Wolverine several X-Men cast members
Fantastic Four ones and so on and so
forth King will have ravaged multiple
Dimensions at this point and there will
be a final stand against him now this is
pretty much every single Marvel Fan's
dream have all of the Marvel characters
together or at least most of them at the
same time but there's actually kind of
an underlying secretly cool thing about
Kevin feige wanting to include past
franchises of Marvel into this movie I
mean obviously just visually it would be
fantastic but Kevin feige actually
worked on all of these past franchises
he worked on all of these previous
movies the X-Men films the Fantastic
Four films the Spider-Man films in the
2000 X-Men movie he was an associate
producer in the 2002 Spider-Man movie
and executive producer he even was a
co-producer on Daredevil X-Men 2 he was
a producer for the Hulk the list is
extremely long pretty much every single
Marvel project including Blade the
original blade not the one that's about
to be rebooted and the Fantastic Four so
this is probably a dream come true for
Kevin feige he is going to get to
include characters from old franchises
that he worked on that started his
career this was before the MCU existed
and before he became president of Marvel
Studios so what a perfect opportunity to
kind of combine his past with the future
I really think this is pretty cool and
congrats to Kevin feige on this but what
is gonna be even cooler for the fans is
seeing all of these characters on screen
together now what is the reason for them
doing this is it just for Fanfare is it
just to please the fans no but Avengers
end game did set the bar pretty dang
high and having all of these characters
on screen together is certainly a way to
out do and go bigger than Avengers end
game now who exactly can we expect to
see but first big thank you to wondering
and the official Lord of the Rings the
rings of power podcast for sponsoring
this video now I know a lot of you you
like me have watched The Lord of the
Rings the rings of power on Amazon it's
amazing I loved it and since you're on
my Channel right now you probably love
to dive even deeper than just watching
the show and now you can go deeper into
the canals of numenor the minds of
kazadum and more with the official the
Lord of the Rings rings of power podcast
host Felicia Day who many people
probably know and several special guests
provide an inside look at the
groundbreaking series and what it took
to bring Middle Earth to life each
episode of the official podcast features
exclusive interviews with the series
showrunner DJ Payne and Patrick McKay
including the very first full breakdown
of the incredible season finale Felicia
also goes behind the scenes with the
cast and crew to bring you jaw-dropping
stories and Easter eggs you won't want
to miss watch the rings of power on
Prime video and listen to all eight
episodes of the official the Lord of the
Rings the rings of power podcast for
free on Amazon music download the Amazon
music app right now to listen to The
Lord of the Rings the rings of power
podcast well given Kevin feige's plans
we can expect to see a lot of different
characters show up and like I mentioned
Kevin feige was pretty much involved
with every single Marvel project
starting with the year 2000 X-Men so
basically if any Marvel character at all
has been on screen before that character
is fair game and could very well end up
in Avengers Secret Wars now of course we
could see characters that haven't been
on screen yet and we could see simply
different variants of them this is what
happened in Multiverse of Madness we saw
Reed Richards Mr Fantastic he does not
exist in our main Universe yet but they
still introduced him and showed him on
screen anyways you could probably expect
the same thing to happen we will see
past present and future superheroes in
secret Wars now as far as the actual
scene is concerned Paul says that Kevin
feige's vision is to have a scene pretty
similar to the portal scene in Avengers
endgame that doesn't mean that this will
necessarily be a portals scene however I
do think that in some way shape or form
it will essentially be somewhat of a
portal scene just not necessarily done
by doctor strange I think that it will
actually be more like when we saw Reed
Richards appear in the Illuminati scene
in Multiverse of Madness I think it's
going to be actual multiversal
technology that is going to be used to
bring all of these other characters from
different universes into one main
Universe after all in the comics
Nathaniel Richards aka the original King
the Conqueror is said to be a descendant
of Reed Richards Mr Fantastic and a lot
of fans really noticed that the
technology that was used in Multiverse
of Madness that teleported Reed Richards
into the room looked a lot like the
technology that the TVA used to open up
their portals so they probably could
link the two so I'm assuming that this
is the technology going to be used to
teleport everybody to the same universe
we could even see the Council of reads
at least a variation of the Council of
reads but I believe that this could be
how the universe is all communicate with
each other and plan to come together to
fight against Kang before the entire or
Multiverse is destroyed this entire
scene kind of seems like a no-brainer at
this point based off of what Marvel
Studios has already been developing
especially if you consider what happened
in Multiverse Madness including the
post-credits scene where they talk about
incursions and how incursions have
already happened in the Multiverse
eventually we're going to get to the
point where universes are simply
disappearing and being wiped away and
Kang the Conqueror is going to also
conquer many different universes as well
and have a multiversal army so it will
eventually get to the point where all of
the heroes from the different universes
will have to come together and unite to
take on King the Conqueror and what's
really cool is that this could happen in
one universe or it could happen in
multiple different universes so the
potential for Secret Wars to be the
biggest movie of all time is definitely
there especially if Kevin feige does get
his wish and pulls this scene off which
I have no doubt that this will happen
but let me know your thoughts about it
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on all the latest MCU news
for live updates you can follow me on
Instagram Graham and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof